[Musique]
cinq semaines cinq semaines tout juste
avant le scrutin européen bonjour à tous
dimanche en politique créé l'événement
ce matin en réunissant 6 candidats de
bourgogne franche comté aux élections
européennes du 26 mai je vous précise
d'emblée qu'il s'agit d'un premier débat
y en aura d'autres sur votre chaîne
régionale avec d'autres candidats
d'autres formations politiques
vous comprendrez aisément qu'il nous est
matériellement impossible de réunir une
douzaine de candidats sur ce plateau
mais soyez sûrs que nous donnerons la
parole au maximum de représentants
politiques au cours de cette campagne
des européennes dans le respect des
règles qui nous sont imposées par le csa
à savoir l'équité des temps de parole
nos candidats ce matin je vous les
présente tout de suite d'abord
christophe grudler vous êtes candidat de
la liste renaissance liste menée par
nathalie l'oiseau c'est la liste de la
république en marche vous faites vous
partie du modem de françois bayrou
associés donc au parti présidentiel
d'emmanuel macron vous êtes 20e sur
cette liste également sur ce plateau
jacques ricart des ti candidat du
rassemblement national de marine le pen
votre liste est menée par jordan bad
bardella vous êtes-vous 49e sur la liste
aux européennes également avec nous
laurence lyonnais de la france insoumise
candidate de la liste l'avenir en commun
en europe aussi liste menée par manon
aubry pour présenter donc la france
insoumise de jean luc mélenchon vous
êtes 11e sur la liste aux européennes
anna maillard candidate de la liste
europe écologie les verts menée par
yannick jadot vous êtes 38e sur cette
liste marc mantovani de debout la france
candidats de la liste les amoureux de la
france menée par nicolas dupont aignan
vous serez 29e sur la liste proposée aux
électeurs et puis didier klein candidats
de la liste de les européens
udi de jean christophe lagarde le
président de l'udps et y donc l'union
des démocrates et indépendants vous êtes
vous aussi
29e sur votre liste bonjour à tous les
six merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors jeu comme d'habitude
vous aussi devant votre télévision vous
pouvez commenter l'émission y participer
sur les réseaux sociaux avec le mot diaz
qui s'affiche dit mme paul bfc comme
dimanche en politique franche comté
alors madame messieurs au cours de
l'heure qui vient nous allons débattre
de la politique européenne en matière
d'industrie en matière de transition
énergétique et écologique
nous parlerons également des services
publics mais d'abord je vous propose une
quarantaine de secondes à chacun chacune
pour vous présenter nous dire pourquoi
vous êtes candidat
et le tirage au sort a désigné pour
commencer marque mantovani
dites nous pourquoi vous êtes candidat
et qui vous êtes
bonjour à toutes et tous alors je suis
candidat de haute saône
parce que nicolas dupont-aignan ont
souhaité qui est quelqu'un des
territoires abandonnés et je suis
candidat pour défendre deux idées
essentielles qui sont défendues par
nicolas dupont aignan la première c'est
rendre à aux nations leur souveraineté
et la deuxième c'est de travailler avec
cette europe qui est aujourd'hui en
panne qui ne fonctionne pas avec des
projets des projets concernant
l'industrie l'environnement la médecine
et les technologies de demain qui sont
très importantes pour les futurs métiers
qui vont apparaître
on va en reparler j'imagine au cours de
ce débat anna maillard c'est à vous
pourquoi vous êtes candidate et qui êtes
vous alors je suis né à belfort et je
vis toujours dans le nord franche comté
je suis venu avec une mauvaise nouvelle
dérèglement climatique nous met tous en
danger mais je suis venu aussi avec une
bonne nouvelle l'europe est le bon
périmètre pour préparer notre avenir à
tous je suis candidat pour porter un
projet d'une refonte un projet de
refonte de l'europe pour une europe
écologique sociale et solidaire
christophe grudler c'est à vous eh bien
je suis candidat parce que je crois à
une europe qui améliorent le quotidien
des gens je suis candidat parce que je
crois à une europe qui protège au niveau
social au niveau économique au niveau
environnemental au niveau fiscal il ya
beaucoup de domaines sur laquelle
l'europe peut nous protéger doit nous
protéger je suis ensuite candidat parce
que je crois en cette liste renaissance
conduite par un atelier l'oiseau qui
associe les compétences et je suis
candidat enfin parce que je crois qu'il
faut qu'il y ait demain un député
européen originaire de franche-comté
pour porter les dossiers de la région au
niveau de strasbourg je pense notamment
aux dossiers industriels au dossier
agroalimentaire voir une relation avec
la suisse s'il ya quelqu'un du terroir
c'est quand même mieux pour porter le
dossier laurence lyonnais qui êtes-vous
pourquoi êtes-vous candidate
bonjour main je viens de frasne dans le
haut doubs et donc je suis candidate sur
cette liste qui notre liste à des
candidats dans toutes les régions de
france
évidemment et dans les dom-tom aussi et
je porte particulièrement les questions
de la ruralité des questions agricoles
et les questions d'accès aux services
publics dans cette liste donc maintenant
le peuple puisque nous avons un
regroupement européen pour porter la
voix de l'insoumission face aux traités
européens qui ne permettent pas
aujourd'hui de conduire des politiques
sociales environnementales à la hauteur
des enjeux et surtout des traités
européens qui nous conduisent dans
l'impasse démocratique avec un déni de
la souveraineté populaire telle qu'on
l'a vécu avec le non au traité
constitutionnel en 2005 j'étais déjà de
cette mobilisation n'a donc on continue
maintenant didier klein à votre tour de
vous présenter didier klein don que mère
de taille cours et vice président de
l'agglomération un pays de montbéliard
agglomération et donc moi j'ai en charge
l'industrie donc c'est un des domaines
importants pour moi au niveau européen
et quand l'idée il m'a demandé de
participer à cette liste européenne
j'ai foncé à l'intérieur pour remonter
les informations les informations du
terrain et donc ma participation dans
c'était europe du futur c'est de
participer d'allier les compétences que
l'on pourra faire avec mes collègues de
l'ue dei est le dernier à se présenter
c'est jacques ricart des t-bonds jour
qui êtes vous pourquoi êtes vous
candidat jour jacques rugard des titres
donc je suis maire d'une petite commune
sur le canton de rougemont qui est
devenu contre bourg madame je suis
conseiller régional je suis sur cette
liste pour l'avenir pour l'avenir de mes
enfants de mes quatre enfants pour
l'avenir du pays
pour l'avenir de cette europe qui reste
à construire elle est à construire
derrière le socle des nations elle est à
construire dans la plus de démocratie et
dans les coupes des peuples nous avons
la chance d'avoir une tête de lit jordan
bardella qui est jeune qui représente
lui aussi l'avenir dans la droite ligne
de la génération de celle de mes enfants
donc nous sommes une nouvelle nous
sommes notre voie est en passe d'être
entendu les nations la notion de vie est
importante et nous avons maintenant deux
nouveaux alliés en europe
merci à tous les six pour ce premier
tour de table on a déjà vu les priorités
des uns des autres tout de suite le
premier thème de ce débat
[Musique]
et ce thème comme une évidence c'est
quelle politique industrielle en europe
nous vivons en bourgogne franche comté
c'est la première région industrielle de
france on a beaucoup parlé très
récemment encore de l'échec de la fusion
alstom siemens pourtant défendue à la
fois par les gouvernements français et
allemand fusion qui s'est heurtée au
veto de la commission européenne au nom
de la libre concurrence alors quelle
politique européenne pour notre
industrie
didier quand je me tourne d'abord vers
vous je me suis penché sur le programme
de l'udps et y l'est républicain et on
peut y lire l'europe et naïve quand elle
ouvre largement ses marchés publics aux
entreprises extra européenne les
libéraux sont ils en train de devenir
protectionnistes les didier kla pas
protectionniste mais on va dire sens et
on a hero filmé euro béats et on a
vraiment l'envi de de faire évoluer
cette europe pour que justement ce qui
se passe dans le monde on a une
mondialisation autour de nous et il faut
vraiment que l'europe puisse pas dire
s'imposer dans ces richesses
industrielles on a des secteurs
industriels vous l'avez dit siemens
alstom psa renault volkswagen qui sont
vraiment des puissances forte locale et
il faut les privilégiés aujourd'hui on a
dans l'industrie des des pans entiers
parfois qu'ils sont ouverts à
l'international alors que sur le marché
chinois sur le marché américain
on ne peut pas aller les entreprises
européennes ne peuvent pas y aller et
donc c'est aussi là qu'il faut à notre
sens trouver des moyens pour s'imposer
pour se remettre
on va dire dans la course et développer
notre industrie mais on est d'accord
c'est plus de protectionnisme c'est pas
du protectionnisme c'est de
l'organisation européenne efficace le
moko le mot est à vous c'est vous alors
que vous avez pris la parole je vous la
donne risque un culte absolument
déraisonnable de la commission
européenne pour la concurrence libre et
non faussée donc qui conduit à brader
nos savoir faire et notre industrie est
donc ici autour de la table et un
certain nombre effectivement d'euros béa
d'euros défenseur donc je serai curieuse
qui nous disent comment ils comptent
défendre les intérêts industriels
et vous alors simplement les intérêts
industriels exemple des raisons dites
nous venons et comment nous réserver la
l'emploi pour un protectionnisme social
et solidaire afin de préserver ses
savoir faire industriel en priorité et
les
emploi qui aujourd'hui sont plus que
menacé puisque on a une destruction
d'emplois industriels notamment dans
notre région sur le site d'alstom sur le
site de psa sochaux et l'état parce que
aussi des responsabilités de détail à la
commission européenne mais
responsabilité de l'état aussi au
premier rang desquels emmanuel macron
qui a participé quand même à ce
détricotage de la du protectionnisme
industriel et qui a laissé cac abandonné
finalement notre industrie donc là
dessus on a quand même pas mal de choses
à dire sur la rendant giovanni je suis
extraordinairement d'accord avec vous et
ben voilà les alliances secret sur ce
plateau le au bout de dix minutes
d'émission et nous protéger de l'air ce
qui est totalement faux ça serait de
plus de temps liu millions de pauvres de
plus en france une désindustrialisation
de notre pays un nombre de chô mage qui
n'a fait que croître
sans parler des des mal-logés et des
gens qui qui s'ouvre il ya plus
d'entreprises aujourd'hui qui
disparaissent kignan qui créent ou est
la productique protection de l'europe et
n'ayant pas peur de faire du
protectionnisme intelligent parce qu'ils
le font tous même l'allemagne la chine
les etats unis n'en parlons pas mais
font tous du protectionnisme il faut
repérer m déjà à la france qu'elle
serait industrialise notamment dans
noter nos territoires par incitations
fiscales avec non pas sur un principe de
subventionner mais d'éviter de prendre
ce qui sous-entend que l'état français
vers vous blessez essonne à ces échelles
d'économies très importante parce que
personne ne parle du déficit budgétaire
chronique qui aussi entre 75 et 80
milliards de francs annuels et on va on
augmente d'année en année
notre contribution financière à une
europe qui nous a pas protégés cas pas
de vision pour l'industrie qui prend les
grilles culture est en cours mois pour
la transition énergétique anna maillard
vous aussi vous êtes pour un
protectionnisme chez europe ecologie les
verts mais en protectionnisme vert
ça veut dire quoi c'est ce qui manque
dans les propos que j'ai entendus
effectivement il ya besoin de dresser un
bouclier vert sur l'europe pour
justement éviter les importations de
produits qui n'aurait pas les mêmes
normes environnementales que celle qu on
pourrait appliquer sur le territoire
européen
c'est ce qui a tué notre industrie des
panneaux photovoltaïques lyonnaise quand
les américains taxés à 200 pourtant 200%
les importations chinoises la france
l'europe n'a pas fait d'heureux n'avait
pas agi à ce moment l'europe
nous avons défendu qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait ah bah c'est pour ça que l'europe
est un outil et cet outil nous on
travaille avec un programme
on ne jette pas tout de façon arbitraire
on est en position future d'un tel outil
oui oui et ça se fait collégialement ça
je pense que ça se fait que la
concertation collégialement avec les
entreprises
c'est pas de l'arbitraire on est moi si
vous voulez bien moi je vais je vais
reprendre comme les fondamentaux autour
de cette table il ya très peu de
personnes qui étaient pour le
protectionnisme le protectionnisme
intelligent c'est je pense que c'est
marine le pen est leur assemblée
nationale qui en a parlé en premier je
vois que tout le monde se convertit au
protectionnisme parce qu'on voit que
cette europe telle qu'elle a été
construite elle ne marche pas j'attends
avec intérêt messieurs drider qui va
nous parler de qui va nous parler d'
alstom il va savoir il sait de quoi il
parle il est il et il est une personne
qui qui soutient emmanuel macron qu'on a
vu arriver avec un avec un costume
d'ouvriers alstom et qui a bradé alstom
general electric pour sa branche turbine
voilà j'attends de voir les solutions de
ces gens là moi je trouve qu'ils sont à
géométrie variable aujourd'hui sont pour
le protectionnisme
hier ils étaient pour lou pour l'europe
ouverte aux quatre-vents ça me paraît
difficile de soutenir d'un
protectionnisme
quand on a tout fait depuis depuis
plusieurs années au sein de différents
groupes européens et qu'on n'a rien fait
en parlant mais je l'aï variable article
35 du programme de marine le pen en 2010
est instauré un protectionnisme
intelligent et rétablir une monnaie
nationale adaptée à notre économie va
écouter je vais vous répondre parce que
bien évidemment à chaque fois le
l'histoire de là mais vous avez tout le
monde la loi de changer mais oh qu'est
ce que ça peut être mes lèvres du coup
vous vous avez le rétablissement de la
monnaie nationale vous avez relevé que
le protectionnisme intelligent c'est
nous qui en avons parlé et c'est pas
d'hier
pour l'histoire de la monnaie vous et
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que depuis
quelques temps en europe
nous avons des alliés s'étaient pas le
cas c'était pas qu'elle ya cinq ans les
cinq ans qui nous entoure est précédée
ces deux voix cette voix nationales et
de protection et de protection nationale
n existait pas maintenant nous avons des
alliés au sein de l'europe
nous avons bon espoir de faire changer
cette dernière de par l'intérieur et
donc l'histoire de la monnaie devient
accessoire quand nous étions seuls la
seule solution c'était c'était le levier
de la monnaie ce n'est plus le cas reste
à vrai dire vous avez été un peu attaqué
là dans les cinq dernières minutes que
répondez vous est ce que l'europe
protège en effet comme vous nous l'avez
dit en introduction
alors le problème c'est que c'est pas le
libéralisme ou le protectionnisme le
problème c'est un commerce mondial
équitable ce qui d'ailleurs a manqué
effectivement à l'europe ces derniers
temps c'est qu'une europe qui protège
ses industries c'est une europe aussi
qui sait condamné les pays qui ne
respectent pas les ouvertures de marché
ce que nos entreprises si vous supprimez
l'exportation pour la pour la franche
comté la bourgogne franche comté et bien
demain c'est des milliers de gens au
chômage des millions en fait il faut
aller sur les marchés extérieurs que les
entreprises puissent également des
autres pays puissent venir chez nous ça
c'est parfaitement cohérent mais il y a
il y a mais ça veut dire il ya des
règles réciproque
l'accord donné j'ai changé avec le japon
a permis de doubler nos ventes de vins
régionaux au japon par exemple
par exemple donc l'accord la chaux avec
le canada l'accord avec le canada
l'accord avec le canada ces gens venus
au secours qui tient ces vents
contraires de la pratique se font les
républicains avec le modem au parlement
au monsieur mon travail on a laissé
finir seul regret la moindre des choses
c'est de se respecter et s'écoutent et
réciproquement écouté au moins mes idées
donc je vous disais que l'accord avec le
canada c'est + 9 % de progression de nos
échanges avec le canada et c'est de
l'emploi en france on peut pas se
replier sur nous comme une coquille
parce que demain il ya plus d'emplois
je vous dirai ensuite c'est que notre
plan industriel en 2018 pour la première
fois en vingt ans il a progressé notre
pays encore de façon assez insuffisante
mais il a progressé une dit tu ne dis
pas tu ne dit pas ça continue l'action a
baissé sur le dossier alstom puisque
vous m'avez interpellé le dessus
rapidement et après on est tourné alors
qu'il ya plein de choses à dire en cours
sur la douce je sais bien mais nos
révélations gênantes en double à
l'origine de l'avant alstom si vous me
permettez moi je suis ce dossier va
essayer de le laisser si j'arrive à
m'exprimer
si c'est possible bon donc le dossier
alsthom je le fis de longue date
je peux vous dire que il ya au moment du
rachat d'alstom par jean électrique
les salariés les syndicats tous les élus
tout le monde disait general electric
c'est génial c'est son faux c'est génial
bon sauf si on va refaire l'histoire
belgique allait finissez s'il vous plaît
peut-être qu'à l'époque le rachat par
deux parades alstom par general electric
pardon a permis aussi un plan de
licenciement qui était prévu à l'époque
on savait qu alstom risquer un jour
l'autre de faire un plan de licenciement
il ya trois ans mais c'est incroyable ça
c'était à l'époque et encore aujourd'hui
ils font aujourd'hui il faut clairement
que le rôle rechange de doctrine le
problème de l'europe aujourd'hui c'est
que leur fraîcheur et leur elle veut
protéger son jeu je veux vraiment avoir
du mal à aimer vous avez rattrapé énorme
vous êtes premier au temps de parole
maintenant je disais simplement que la
politique européenne elle doit soutenir
l'industrie par rapport au monde et pas
seulement garantir l'ouverture interne
du marché donc ça donc ça veut dire à
l'équipe aux sauniers d'innovation il
faut soutenir de la versification m
vous parlez tous en même temps c'est
fini anna maillard
j'ai trouvé dans le programme une phrase
qui m'a interpellé l'europe doit tourner
le dos aux industries barbares comme les
robots tueurs
on peut réellement selon vous préserver
l'emploi industriel sans robot faire des
industries sans robben ans c'était des
histoires de taxer la robotisation à
mener dans les entreprises pour pouvoir
maintenir un emploi salariale mais voilà
là vous tombez vraiment sur un point de
cristallisation d'humilité en gras dans
votre programme oui j'ai volé j'ai
essayé de lire les programmes des uns
des autres pour préparer cette émission
on peut voir la robotisation la
numérisation des emplois comme quelque
chose de menaçant mais en fait c'est
aussi quelque chose d'une technologie de
nos industries industries vont pouvoir
s'approprier développer et on à moi ce
qui m'a manqué dans les propos que
j'entends ici c'est de travailler sur
tout l'écosystème industrielle on assure
le nord franche comté la possibilité on
a une wii on a eu monsieur mantovani je
suis juste vous demander d'arrêter c'est
d'arrêter d'intérêt systématiquement les
autres alors je pense que là
l'expression de nos programmes ce robot
tueur d'emplois mais en fait les si on
n'accompagne pas en même temps la montée
en compétences des salariés
oui ont le réflexe pour aide les dents
remplacé lundi claude didier klein vous
en pensez quoi
il essaie des choses assez proche on est
tous en train de regarder du social de
la production mais surtout du fait que
nos entreprises elles doivent pouvoir
vendre à des prix intéressants et que on
peut pas faire que du protectionnisme
on est obligé d'être attentif pour
répondre à ce que vos journées d'autres
lama mais derrière et en scène suisse
vendre il faut qu'on puisse donc avoir
une production une évolution accroît de
la formation à croître aussi les
conditions de travail parce que c'est
aussi important on a
c'est tous les jours dans psa on a
vraiment d une évolution énorme de
moyens de production une numérisation
des robots qui apparaissent mais aussi
des gens qui vont traiter des robots qui
vont aussi avoir à avoir des formations
autour de cette numérisation de
l'entreprise est aujourd'hui on parle
plus de 4.0 parle de quatre points lâche
donc c'est une évolution très importante
de nos entreprises
laurence yonnais ce serait bien que les
robots soit au service des humains et
pas l'un vers ce que l'on voit dans
certains développements industriels ou
dans les sites de vente notamment
moi ce que je constate c'est que
personne ne dit qu'il faut sortir de
certaines dispositions des traités qui
prévoit la libre circulation des
capitaux et qui permette l'évasion
fiscale qu'on ne revient pas sur
l'interdiction de position de monopole
d'état alors qu'on en aurait besoin pour
conduire une transition écologique dans
les secteurs stratégiques de l'énergie
et des transports des télécoms et de la
santé donc là ces propositions là ne
sont pas faites monsieur grue de l'air
vous avez fait appel à emmanuel macron
c'est un petit peu comme si vous appelle
au pyromane pour sauver notre industrie
c'est lui qui a participé à la
catastrophe industrielle sur le site
d'allston tant qu'on ne reviendra pas
sur ses concessions aux actionnaires et
cette collusion avec la haute finance a
voulu être un visite obligée de retarder
voulait très rapidement en 20 secondes
vous répondez à leurs anciens lyonnais
on sait qu'aujourd'hui il y a un enjeu
devant nous par rapport à gêner les
tricks à l'avenir des salariés et je
vous assure que le président de la
république s'en préoccupent
personnellement je peux vous assurer
qu'il ya actuellement des gens qui
travaillent avec les syndicats avec les
élus au niveau de l'elysée au niveau des
ministères pour trouver des solutions
face à cette catastrophe ce qui est
annoncé donc je peux vous dire les
accusations c'est vraiment un délai
faire ce qu'il faut faire il faut ces
moments là c'est se rassembler je pense
que les salariés et il faut bien se
rassembler et pas chahuter création
aller ch doit se rassembler sur des
dossiers industriels aussi meubles
mesdames messieurs on arrête le chef je
vous propose d'écouter à présent un
candidat d'une autre formation politique
michel treppo de lutte ouvrière
sa liste est menée par un nathalie
arthaud on l'écouté on revient juste
après pour un nouveau débat nous voulons
l'europe socialiste des travailleurs
pas dans l'intérêt comme ça a été fait
actuellement pour l'intérêt des grands
groupes capitalistes
cette europe a été construite pour leur
intérêt pour leur profit pour que le
capitaux n'est pas de frontières pour se
déplacer sans payer taxes ou quoi que ce
soit ben nous on veut que ce soit une
europe sociale par les travailleurs mais
ça ne deviendra que par des grandes
luttes d'ensemble ça peut commencer dans
un pays
et quand quand c'est exposé dans un pays
on sait très bien que ça peut contaminer
les autres
et moi j'en suis persuadé j'en suis
convaincu ce grand capital en veut
tellement vieux de plus en plus de
profits sur le dos des salariés sur le
dos des travailleurs qu'il y aura des
explosions inévitable allez si vous nous
rejoignez maintenant sachez que vous
êtes dans une émission spéciale dans
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne et france 3 franche comté nous
avons réuni à cinq semaines du scrutin
européen six candidats de notre région
aux élections européennes du 26 mai
deuxième thème de ce débat la transition
énergétique et écologique l'europe se
veut à la pointe dans ce domaine mais
l'est-elle vraiment rendre plus verte
notre société notre économie
n'est-il pas sans risque anna maillard
on attend forcément beaucoup les
écologistes sur cette question l'europe
en fait-elle assez pour l'environnement
largement non c'est pour ça qu'on
propose que cette europe deviennent
notre outil pour une transition
écologique
on propose un peu dans l'histoire de
l'ancienne communauté économique du
charbon et de l'acier ça représente à
une époque du développement européen
mais qui aujourd'hui nous met en danger
sur la consommation des ressources
naturelles et les émissions de co2 on
propose maintenant une comète une
communauté européenne de la transition
énergétique qui permettrait en
pénalisant les
les entreprises polluantes les pollueurs
de réinjecter ces moyens dans le
développement d'industries moins
polluantes et également donc on parle
souvent enfin moi je voulais souligner
deux aspects ya à la fois le besoin
d'accompagner le développement
d'industries moins polluantes et
vertueuse ça peut être un peu le
recyclage des déchets voilà typiquement
c'est une industrie mais également
d'accompagner les industries les tpe les
pme dans leur isolation dans
l'utilisation de leur cycle dauphin il
ya toujours il faudrait qu'on puisse
avancer sur les deux facettes et là
l'europe vraiment un outil important
j'ai pas pu terminer tout à l'heure ce
que je voulais développer sur les
écosystèmes locaux
parce qu'en fait sur les terroirs dans
le nord franche comté on a intérêt à
voir industriel mais il est européen en
fait il est d'ampleur européenne
les robots qu'on fabrique dans les
industries du nord franche comté ils
sont aussi utilisés dans d'autres
bassins européens dans d'autres bassins
mondiaux donc en réinjectant ce contact
chez les néfastes et chez les pollueurs
on peut soutenir une industrie plus
vertueuses et je ne l'oublions pas les
tpe pme qui sont très importantes aussi
pour le tissu et qu'elle souvent sont
démunis pour mettre en place des plans
d'action donc une agence également
d'accompagnement ondes le modèle de
l'ademe par exemple en france pour
accompagner les ménages
l'ademe accompagne aussi les entreprises
françaises mais c'est encore assez mal
connu donc là il ya des bleus il ya un
levier intéressant
sa demande de l'engagement politique et
de l'engagement de fonds publics marc
mantovani l'europe en fait assez pour
l'environnement non la transition
écologique s'effectue très mal en europe
parce que il ya quelque chose qu'il faut
intégrer c'est là la différence des
profils énergétique des pays qui sont
complètement différents l'allemagne
c'est le charbon nous pays quand même
avant dernier en tant que mode moins
pollueur alors que l'allemagne est en
tête fait partie du peloton
c'est grâce où il me fallait dans le
peloton des dpi
je suis jeune et j'ai très élevé à mai
avec les le sait le choisissent le choix
qu'ils ont fait dans les tribunes et
celui d' interrompre on va essayer pas
interrompre monsieur mantovani chacun
senteurs mais balesi finissait alors moi
je suis très sensible à ce sujet parce
que figurez vous que je vais être
grand-père dont peu de temps je ne veux
pas laisser le monde dans lequel nous
vivons est celui qui arrive à très court
terme à mes petits enfants parce qu'on
va être tous impact et ça c'est le
constat mais cas nous on fait maintenant
roumanie alors déjà la première chose
qu'il faut relocaliser l'emploi en
france avec les entreprises qui
exportent avec des bateaux cargo qui
sont extrêmement polluant que nous nous
proposons de taxer avait une douane une
taxe de pollution
et puis nous nous nous souhaitons
également la création dans chaque région
d'un livret épargne rémunéré qui servent
au développement et à l'environnement et
tous les métiers de demain de demain qui
sont inhérents je dis tout net faut pas
avoir peur d'allah survie de l'humanité
ne pourra pas continuer comme ça c'est
impossible et il faut une politique très
très fort vous parlez de livrer ça me
fait penser à quelque chose nous nos
ressources naturelles sont limitées
elles sont finis tous nos ressources
financières aussi donc on doit avancer
en vase clos
donc ce qu'on gaspille sur des énergies
polluantes ont subventions d'énergies
polluantes et encore 4 milliards d'euros
qui sont versés aux les industries
d'extraction à deux voiles du pétrole ah
ben on va pas se battre sur les chiffres
parce qu'on va en trouver différents
mais on est dans un monde fini donc ses
moyens financiers il n'y a pas de
l'argent magique qui va tomber quelque
part nous c'est vraiment de en vase clos
d'arrêter de verser où il est
dispendieux et inefficace et pour
accompagner celles qui en ont besoin
didier klein il ya aussi un livret
environnement dans le programme de
l'union européen environnement il fait
il a il a les deux et c'est vrai que
c'est important pour nous de mobiliser
des finances et surtout de regarder ce
qui est mais on peut toujours regarder
que c'est nucléaires et à charbon et
tout mais il faut aussi évoluer il faut
aller vers de nouvelles recherches
c'est mon côté universitaire et
chercheur mais à l'hydrogène
hong hao
si dans notre bassin industriel et là on
peut très vite être en avance sur
d'autres pays donc pour développer mais
pas que on recherche mais également dans
la pratique de tous les jours pour avoir
de nouvelles énergies des énergies
propres qui soit qui puisse être après
eux mêmes couples et l'automobile à
l'industrie c'est ce qui m'intéresse le
plus pour ma part ou même alstom sera de
nouveau développement mais sera des
développements européens
c'est important pour moi c'est pas un
développement qu'on va faire franco
français non il est impossible
aujourd'hui
si on ne travaille pas au niveau de
l'europe pour l'environnement comme pour
l'industrie
on n'arrivera pas à s'exprimer laurence
lyonnais oui nous on est pour une
politique de l'énergie commune qui
serait un petit peu l'équivalent d'un
petit qu'agricole commune mais qui
répondent à des objectifs d'intérêt
général ces mêmes et de ruraux que ça
vous êtes pour une planification écolo à
la mesa ça impose de pouvoir sortir des
traités européens qui interdisent les
positions de monopole qui prévoit la
privatisation des services publics
vous avez participé avec europe ecologie
les verts à ces traités on parlera des
services publics après en bêtes par
exemple sur l'environnement et bien
c'est quand même une question de service
public ce que des services publics de
l'énergie
là on a des mesures de privatisation des
belges des barrages qui ont été entamées
sous le gouvernement de françois
hollande
donc ils nous privent des ressources
pour conduire cette transition
énergétique
on met en concurrence les services
publics et du coup on peut pas conduire
la transition énergétique non plus dans
le dans le secteur des transports
l'union européenne aujourd'hui c'est
l'inaction climatique et il faut que ce
soit un mouvement dans la jeunesse qui
s'est levé depuis plusieurs mois il ya
eu des manifestations ce vendredi des
blocages à paris sur les industries les
plus polluantes
c'est cette jeunesse aujourd'hui qui se
lève et qui exige que l'europe fasse
enfin ce qu'elle aurait dû commencer à
faire déjà hier et ce qu'elle reporte
toujours à demain par exemple un
objectif de 32 % d'énergies
renouvelables en 2030 c'est absolument
insuffisant mais pour ça il faut qu'on
puisse prendre la main effectivement sur
les strictes des secteurs stratégiques
au niveau des états et au niveau
européen et se donner des objectifs
communs aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
traités ce n'est pas possible
et alors sur l'argent magique je
regrette on peut survivre avec 3 % de
déficit ne pourra pas survivre avec
trois degrés de réchauffement climatique
donc oui de l'argent il y en a et puis
aujourd'hui on n'est pas obligé non plus
d'être sous la coupe d'une banque
centrale européenne qui nous empêche
d'émettre de la monnaie est d'être
maîtres de notre destinée
kim a donc attendez nous si vous sortiez
cette europe prévient donc vous vous
sortez des traités oui on peut pas
compter un à maya vous répandez très
rapidement et puis après on passe ce qui
ne se sont pas exprimés sur ce thème à 8
on sort des traités européens permettent
de modifier les traités on va là dessus
et on couvre tout d'un super traité
environnementale pour que celui-là
oriente voulait traiter l procédure donc
pour la modification des traités vous
qu'on va sortir du dialogue entre autres
à changer on va changer les fois dire
que christophe de l'air sûr alors pour
l'instant il n'y a pas vraiment de
programme à renaissance il ya la lettre
des manuels macron qui sert de programme
et le président de la république parle
de de prendre la tête du combat
écologique
c'est très compliqué néanmoins on l'a vu
récemment sur le glyphosate
c'est ma question et je vais vous
demander une réponse très courte parce
que vous avez pris beaucoup d'avancé sur
la première partie au niveau du temps de
parole
alors la réponse était toujours et est
toujours important excusez-moi j'ai
perdu le fil de ce que je souhaitais
prendre la tête
oui du combat écologiste et c'est pas
plus c'est facile à dire pas facile à
faire c'est facile à faire regarder la
france est la seule à s'être opposés
l'ouverture des négociations
commerciales avec les états unis
parce que les états unis ne respecte pas
l'accord de paris
ça c'est une démarche courageuse qui a
été prise par le président de la
république et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui la
voix de la france est entendu en europe
ce que j'aimerais également c'est que la
voix de l'europe soit entendue dans le
monde et que l'europe soit le modèle
pour la transition énergétique qu'ils
puissent parler au monde mais centre est
ce qu'on doit mettre d'accord avec les
partenaires sont là c'est là je vous
renvoie à l'exemple du glyphosate seuls
combats perdus d'avancé les combats qui
ne sont pas menées donc me non ce combat
avec des gens déterminés nous avons des
alliés nous avons balayé dans les autres
pays
nous avons proposé la banque la banque
du climat doté de 2000 milliards d'euros
c'est pascal canfin et pascal durand qui
députés sortants qui ont fait un travail
de grande qualité là dessus nous avons
une banque européenne du climat qui est
proposé nous soutenons des plans
stratégiques industriels européens
ils permettent la mutation
environnementale et dans ce cadre là je
soutiens avec force le projet du pays de
montbéliard autour de l' usine de
batteries qui pourraient installer en
fait chaud
la région bongolava qui comprendra que
l'on puisse à mobiliser ensemble
pourquoi ces jeunes que patrick dé lui
s'y installer quel est le programme
alors monsieur du rassemblement national
un petit mot à monsieur grue de l'air
bon alors bien vouloir vous répondre
interdit de répondre à lons ça
simplement les effets de manche du
président de la république comme les
effets de manche de monsieur dowd leers
et pourrait bien voilà là le combat
écologique de notre ami de votre ami
monsieur macron j'ai pas oublié on a
parlé du glyphosate on pourrait parler
du ceta on pourrait parler tout un tas
de choses donc si vous oubliez pas de la
cli jacques ricart lady parler nous
parlez nous du programme du
rassemblement national ou simplement
simplement ne pensons pas que l'euro
paie et la bonne échelle il ya une telle
disparité comme vous l'avez dit une
telle disparité dans les pays européens
la france et un pour cent des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre l'allemagne
c'est 9%
donc voila nous on pense on pense que
nationalement il faut revenir il faut
revenir à du localisme c'est-à-dire
réserver les marchés vont bien
évidemment cash cacd casser les traités
européens parce que sinon on n'y
arrivera pas un revenir à du localisme
protéger nos marchés que ce soit les
marchés de repas scolaires en terme en
termes d'alimentation haute les réserves
et les réserves et mettre des clauses
henry environnementale sérieuse et est
ferme avec avec un secteur géographique
déterminée éviter une nouvelle façon de
consommer aussi que que l'alpha et
l'oméga l'homme ne soit pas seulement la
consommation et que et sur les énergies
parce qu'on vous entends beaucoup
notamment en bourgogne franche comté
votre combat c'est anti éoliens mais que
tout à fait alors l'éolien pour l'éolien
c'est une vaste escroquerie
l'éolien est aux mains des taux mains
des lobbies de le piste ça ne satisfait
que les personnes qui ont une éolienne
sur leur terrain que ce soit communal ou
privé sans au mépris de au mépris du de
l'écologie est de savoir ce qu'ils
fassent ce qu'ils valent ce qu'on
développe les énergies renouvelables
mais pas l'éolien c'est ça exactement
non mais
claire ces messages ont lieu tout le
monde en vue mais pas tout près de chez
soi ça je peux vous retournez la même
chose pourquoi par exemple en france et
combien on a des aliens offshore il y en
a une
non mais c'est vrai qu'on a des
capacités développer l'éolien il ya
beaucoup de projets notamment dans lors
de ce squale éolien offshore on est
surtout les mêmes ceux ci se soient
livrés on laisse finir voilà que ce
serait bien que ce soit l'éolien
offshore ou l'éolien terrestre on est
systématiquement contre c'est une
énergie dispendieuse qui a besoin de
l'énergie fossile
continuer le nucléaire ont fonctionné
voilà une alternative je pense que la
filière nucléaire française une filière
d'excellence doit être développée et que
le p r doit être développé une énergie
propre idée qui n'émet pas de gaz à nant
décarbonée on a compris que vous n'étiez
pas d'accord notamment oui mais non je
suis désolé c'est fini c'est fini sur
cette thématique là si vous voulez
parler des services plus vous avez parlé
des services publics tout à l'heure on
va parler des services publics mais
d'abord on écoute un autre candidat
d'une autre formation politique il
s'agit de philippe marceau de l'upm
l'union populaire républicaine dont la
liste est menée par françois à ce livre
aujourd'hui quand vous avez un papier
que vous ne pouvez pas modifiée par
exemple imaginons vous êtes marié avec
une personne qui vous trompe que vous ne
pouvez pas modifiées que vous pouvez pas
changer
je ne pouvais pas changer les
comportements de mobilité cette personne
lorsqu'on dit c'est on ne peut pas
modifier on ne peut pas réécrire les
traités européens
donc on quitte l'europe s'est certes
appel d'offres excite justement quelles
sont les priorités du mouvement upr
alors les priorités du mouvement trc de
faire connaître justement toutes ces
lois qui écrase aujourd'hui le peuple
français aussi bien d'un point de vue un
emploi d'un point de vue santé d'un
point de vue environnement puisque de
toute façon toutes les lois européennes
sont faites pour le marché et pour
l'argent et non pas pour l'individu et
le peuple
[Musique]
aller retour sur ce plateau émission
spéciale consacrée aux élections
européennes avec six candidats de
bourgogne franche comté au scrutin du 26
mai l'europe est elle une menace ou une
chance pour nos services publics la
question est prégnante notamment en
bourgogne franche comté ou des services
hospitaliers par exemple ferme sous
couvert de rationalisation alors est ce
la faute de l'europe comme l'accusent
certains l'europe qui impose des
contraintes budgétaires à chacun des
états membres
je me tourne d'abord vers vos christophe
grudler est ce que c'est la faute de
l'europe
il n'ya rien par exemple sur les
services publics dans la lettre d'
emmanuel macron aux européens qui vous
sert de programmes je le rappelle je
vais vous dire que en fait l'europe
effectivement c'est le bouc émissaire tu
sais que quand ça va pas c'est de la
faute à l'europe puis quand ça va bien
c'est grâce à nos politiques nationales
je vous dis que les services publics en
fait sont protégés par l'union
européenne c'est dans les traités c'est
qu'il y à une exclusion notamment des
services publics des négociations
commerciales internationales
donc il y a une vraie protection imposé
par les textes
et puis il ya une réponse à apporter la
réponse c'est les fonds structurels
européens
les crédits feder et autres qui sont
justement là pour financer des
infrastructures publiques
en effet hier se donne la parole et je
vais prouver
un peu de respect s'il vous plaît josé
lecture de ces finir donc s'il vous
plaît donc il y à un soutien aux
infrastructures publiques au service de
tous y compris en milieu rural qui sont
financés par les fédère donc aux
communes de porter des projets aux
intercommunalités de porter les projets
aux départements et aux régions
et derrière il y à des fonds européens
mais qui sont déjà aujourd'hui les fonds
structurels en bourgogne franche comté
c'est énorme le le fonds social européen
c'est aussi énorme un autre niveau
puis on a aujourd'hui une europe qui
arrose 2 millions d'euros fini de
subventions et c'est extrêmement
important de le dire le rend ce trio
n'est vous vous faites clairement à la
france insoumise le lien entre l'europe
et les services publics
oui parce qu'il ya deux volets ya
l'organisation de la privatisation de la
mise en concurrence de nos services
publics dont qui amène à l'est
détricoter on l'a vu avec la poste
on l'a vu avec les télécoms on l'a vu
avec
le rail quatre paquets ferroviaires
quand même au niveau de l'union
européenne pour détricoter à la fois le
fret à la fois les trains de nuit est
maintenant les petites lignes
et après vous allez me dire ah bah oui
mais la région a demandé des fonds à
l'europe pour essayer de pallier la
fermeture des petites lignes c'est pas
sérieux il ya 700 millions d'euros il ya
5 millions d'euros et des cassettes 5
millions d'euros qu'on n'a pas été
capable au niveau des régions et ça
c'est merci la fusion aussi de traiter
sur les fonds européens et qui vont
repartir au niveau de l'union européenne
s'ils sont pas consommés avant 2020 donc
effectivement il ya un lien il ya un
lien aussi sur l'encadrement des 3% à
cette fameuse règle d'or de l'union
européenne que nous on veut remplacer
par une règle verte donc effectivement
il ya une responsabilité éminente de
l'union européenne dans la casse des
services publics didier klein est ce que
comme tout à l'heure vous voler au
secours de christophe grudler je n'ai
aucun souci et je pense que même si on
dit dans le même groupe c'est normal
mais nous on est européen
donc on a le droit d'être un honneur
dans le même groupe parce qu'on
travaille on travaille ensemble
vous avez plutôt dans vos propos une
attitude résulte est un peu on va dire
défendant un peu un certain chauvinisme
plutôt qu'une europe un peu vrai dire
mon verre projet d'un os comme cela fait
je suis très clair là dessus on va
laisser alors est ce qu'on peut entendre
sur la partie on va dire des services
publics
c'est sûr je rappelle toujours parce que
je pense qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont pas
bien regardé la réglementation
européenne
l'europe fait des recommandations les
états les mettre en oeuvre on a dit des
parlementaires
on a un gouvernement et c'est pas celui
ci comme les précédents beaucoup n'ont
pas vraiment mis en oeuvre des
recommandations mais ont un petit peu
mais me plus là moi je regarde beaucoup
la portée environnementale parce que
c'est une de mes fonctions
c'est vrai que parfois on a des
contraintes administratives choisie par
la france et pas on va dire
obligatoirement donnés par l'europe
il y avait des niveaux mais on a été un
peu plus loin parce qu'on aimait bien
vouloir montrer qu'on allait plus loin
que ces messieurs ont filmé sur l'axé a
pas que moi que non sur l'accès aux
services publics didier klein selon vous
c'est la faute de l'aura poussé de la
faute de paris l'accès aux services
publics
ce sont les choix de fermer l'hôpital ce
n'est pas l'europe qui le décide
c'est le succès la france qui le décide
ces idioties monsieur klein les
contraintes budgétaires vous savez très
bien que contrainte budgétaire
aujourd'hui il fait comme moi et lui
c'est la vraie question
moi j'ai très clair mais moi j'ai pas
pour la fermeture des hôpitaux de
proximité
je travaille en développement
clinique dont ils m'ont belliard je
connais un petit peu le sujet et je peux
vous garantir que moi je vous réalité
monsieur klein vous intégrez vous avez
on a des territoires on est
particulièrement touchée je vous parle
même pas de la bourgogne où on laisse
ouvertes on est en haut on doit exister
les boys thomas de la ferme est ouvert
de faire des services de proximité et on
se bat on n'oublie pas que depuis les
années 2000 et je lui borloo l'a
beaucoup fait un moment aussi c'est
d'essayer de mettre en place tout ce
qu'ils étaient et des maisons du service
public pour justement on sait qu'on a de
moins en moins de moyens mais qu'on peut
mettre a dit dans des endroits des
moyens pour que tout le monde puisse se
développer et puissent recevoir le
service public qui est attendu
anna maillard ne s'est pas exprimé sur
ce thème comment on préserve les
services publics et est ce de la faute à
l'europe s'il ya aujourd'hui une
pression sur les services publics
notamment en bourgogne franche comté
l'union européenne actuelle clairement
et n'a pas à la hauteur sur la
protection des services publics alors
une promotion leurs animations
les écologistes prônent le fed enfin les
peuples mais comme service d'intérêts
généraux ce qui n'est pas du tout à fait
un service public est en fait l'europe
peut être un très bon outil
effectivement la journée le bilan des
fonds versés à lui à que la région
bourgogne franche comté a eu à traiter
donc c'est des montants très intéressant
pour se mobiliser tout à fait si je vais
citer un milliard et demi en gros c'est
un milliard et demi sur la bourgogne
franche comté sur la durée d'un mandat
donc cinq ou six en cinq ans je crois
que l'on recevait au site également
l'exemple de jean macé qui avait relevé
dans l'yonne communes rurales profonde
si on peut dire et qui lui s'est appuyé
sur ses fonds européens pour rénover son
école elle à rendre performante et les
fléaux groupe est certes descendu sur le
terrible mais on en perd combien on en
perd avec les agriculteurs n'en perdrons
bien évidemment bien combien on en perd
nombreuses causes que l'on côtoie ici
madame est ce que l'on entre chaumont
cotisent est ce que l'on reçoit
combien berton est ce que vous savez ce
que vous savez combien mon pea dépend de
quel sûr qu'elle s'incarne on ne sait
pas qui est terre de calcul c'est un
critère de quelques combien la france
vers ce monsieur drucbert vous qui
faites et manu voilà 91 lui dire combien
on reçoit ton voilà combien d'eau non
non non non non non
il faut pas être solidaire un an même il
faut pas être solidaire avec les
pays-bas - on est moins développée en
aval du service public qui enseignent
déliquescence et de sujet dont on parle
moi je pense que c'est les nôtres avant
les autres monsieur je le dis pour vous
comme pour les auteurs me disait ça
aussi et on voit le résultat jouer leurs
économies aujourd'hui je vous peuvent
pas vous dire c'est que quand la france
le rôle de l'agent l'europe menace mais
un pays pas de menace d'autres pays on
est mal développe et ne soit plus une
concurrence à nos portes que ces autres
pays achètent nos produits français il
ya un retour direct sur le web et
regarder la rue goethe est passé
l'argent perdu permet à de la mode en
europe de pouvoir acheter nos produits
français mais c'était donc c'est de
l'argent si si l'angleterre veut partir
monsieur bruder c'est la liberté qui
partent
moi je vois un petit pays comme la
suisse avec lequel on commerce qui fait
pas partie de l'union européenne qui
s'en tire très bien qu'il a que des
accords avec l'europe qui doit encore
entre l'union européenne et la suisse
déjà y aurait des sirènes de nuit et on
en profite en bosnie ne s'est pas
exprimée encore sur le sujet à l'europe
de s'occuper des services publics
français c'est pas son rôle
elle est trop éloignée service public
c'est de la proximité l'europe
une fois encore nous a pas protégés de
pour la préservation nos services
publics
il ya des fermetures d'écoles personnels
hospitaliers surchargé avec tous les
problèmes qu'il a eus yeux macron veut
faire des économies sur la masse
salariale d'aider des hôpitaux en france
voilà il ya des choses qu'il faudra
m'expliquer les services publics la
disparition des services publics
les deuce aussi ont fait la france s'est
paupérisée que nous devenons un pays
pauvre qui n'a pu les les moyens lavedan
s'établit pour et veut est devenue un
pays pour on a une dette abyssale la
pays qui est riche il n'a pas de dettes
ils en prennent pas tous les ans aux
organismes financiers pour boucler la
moitié de l'année le gisement fiscal de
la france s'est réduit de décennie en
décennie parce que les entreprises
françaises ont une fiscalité délirante
qu'elles n'ont pas non plus une vision à
long terme de la fiscalité et qu'il ya
plein de gens qui sont partis
délocaliser ailleurs
donc si vous voulez les besoins les taux
oat augmentent augmenté en même temps
que le gisement fiscal a diminué donc on
l'a augmentée quantitativement et
aujourd'hui l'hythane ont nagé mme rey
qu'on a un service public à la hauteur
ici on veut un service public à la
hauteur fort le courage de faire des
économies d'ordre structurel
j'attendais ça monsieur macron toit fuit
des économies monsieur matheron de la
france alors enseigner dans l'est dans
les services publics non mais je note
avec intérêt ce qu'a dit monsieur grue
de l'air ça veut dire qu'il ya un manque
de courage de nos dirigeants vis-à-vis
des des services publics et une saignée
qui opérait actuellement par monsieur
macron il devance les attentes de la
commission européenne c'est formidable
mais les services publics c'est la
richesse de ceux qui n'ont plus rien et
ça c'est vrai qu'on soit en hongrie en
bulgarie
on est les bagnes vous avez trahi notre
voisin quand il dit que la france est
devenue un pays pauvre
non pas du tout mais c'est pas c'est pas
une question de prix mais la richesse de
ceux qui n'ont plus rien c'est pour ça
que je vous remercie on a les moyens
d'avoir des services publics dans tous
les territoires de france
nous on a visité très récemment
l'hôpital de saint-claude
on visite une et ben oui on visite une
maternité qui est extrêmement bien
équipé et qui est fermé un bloc
opératoire qu'on n'a pas fini de payer
voilà et cet hôpital ne fonctionne plus
alors qu'il ya des soignants qui ne
demandent qu'à travailler d une
population qui ne demande qu'à être qu
être soigné cas être prise en charge
alors là et après on ne faut pas nous
donner de leçon à nous d économie et de
bonne gestion parce que quand on n'a pas
fini de payer deux blocs opératoires etc
l'hôpital est déjà fermé qu'est ce que
ça veut dire cette politique de
gribouille
car nous étions les faits ou les
économies écoutez pour le moment pour le
moment c'est très simple si si on
retouche l argent converser à l'europe
n'y aurait pas d'économie d'affaires où
tout le monde nous parle des fonds feder
on a l'impression que c'est une pluie
une manne qui tombe je voulais 10 un
déficit entre ce que nous donnons à ce
que nous recevons je pense que dans
l'état de paupérisation l'état des
services un actionnaire derrière l'état
d'éveil code et service militaire il
doit nous obliger aujourd'hui à
retoucher le moindre centime cordone je
reviendrai à l'état thatchérien un euro
donné à l'europe doit revenir un euro à
la france on est dans un état de
paupérisation comme on l'a tout le monde
ce concept autour de cette table les un
déficit de services publics et un
déficit de scolarité comment se protéger
face à mayence on n'a pas tout à fait
les entre les actionnaires et les
services publics parce que est en
lambeaux pas privé de se payer en impôts
et vous savez quelle vision qu'il faut
c'est de lagonda en moins pour fait
qu'ils possèdent la dette française
l'emprunt carrosse hommage à gauche
l'emprunt français qui le possèdent et
c'est pareil pour les autres pays
européens je connais pas le ratio c'est
les français c'est nos plans déjà
solidaire non il sur lui ce qui est sûr
une aux banques n'ont étendu les
passions voilà de quoi je vous parle ce
sont les milliards d habitants la wii
d'évasion fiscale mes fans me déshabille
nusa dua et la neutralisation des indus
des industries numériques dégâts femmes
dont google facebook amazon willaya de
la digue est actionnaire mais ça aussi
vous savez mais ils ont été grassement
rémunérés là mais en tout cas enfin
voilà on n'est pas trop des services
publics qui sont à part les cliniques
privées
voilà on est sur des peut pas tout tout
tout ce paravent ses anciens critères
budgétaires
europe ecologie les verts dit quoi là
dessus est ce qu'il faut le respecter à
tout prix et s'il faut prendre en compte
la pression qu'ils font peser sur les
finances publiques françaises
non c'est le dogme des 3 % oui c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut lever mais
toujours en réintégrant le critère des
territoires de la protection de l'action
écologique de l'action de la transition
écologique
donc c'est des choses oui qu'on peut
faire varier ses 3 % ça a été décrite sa
a été créée j'avais lu l'histoire de la
création des 3% s'est décidé sur un coin
de bureau en fait ce serait 4 parce que
les deux ennemis en fait faut ce chiffre
là c'est plus comme l'art est magique
on doit mouiller bon à la fusion des
régions ça nous met un bon niveau par
rapport aux autres régions européennes
il ya déjà six ans elle file de la
tendance on a perdu à proximité on nous
avons dû les régions comme étant une
source d'économie au final on sa hausse
avec soin ils ont les mains et en faire
don à proximité moi je crois plus à la
proximité plus on est frais des choix
l'air il est bientôt mines et il est
bientôt midi on va vous proposer un
petit temps de conclusion à chacun et je
reprends mon ordre tirés au sort je vous
accorde 30 à 40 secondes chacun on est
bon sur les temps de parole on a bien
géré tout ça et comme tout à l'heure ses
marques mantovani qui commence pourquoi
faut-il adressez vous aux électeurs de
bourgogne franche comté
pourquoi et comment les convaincre de
voter pour vous je les invite surtout à
aller voter pour qui que ce soit
évidemment je préférerais que ce soit
pour la liste des amoureux de la france
menée par nicolas dupont aignan mais le
vrai enjeu sont tellement énormes
le 26 mai prochain nous avons un choix
historique à faire soit on continue avec
les mêmes socialistes républicains est
les marmitons européiste raw réaliste
heureux et qu'ils nous vendent
finalement le même goût big bull bas
depuis maintenant 25 ans et on
s'aperçoit que ça a des limites et que
cela ne fonctionne pas merci marc
mantovani
la deuxième c'est anna maillard oui
alors je vois que le projet écologiste
inspire des autres listes que soit prise
au rayon des bâtiments les barrières
écologique les pesticides j'ai retrouvé
ça dans les autres programmes politiques
et voilà c'est jean prend note
j'invite les personnes à ne pas se fier
aux à ceux qui verdissent leurs
programmes à l'approché des élections
mais après quand il s'agit de passer aux
actes by ap voilà y'a plus personne
quand il s'agit de siéger au parlement
européen et de voter pour la vraie
protection de l'action un écologiste
je vous invite à donner du poids aux
écologistes dans ce prochain parlement
européen des écologistes qui n'ont
modes de travail et de fonctionnement
finissez la france
la collégialité et toutes les parties
prenantes pas dans l'arbitraire et de
décréter donnez nous les moyens de
réaliser ce projet c'est un scrutin à un
seul tour et c'est fini christophe
grudler votre conclusion si vous mais
que des face aux grands défis du monde
il nous faut une europe unie et
solidaire se replier sur soi-même c'est
mourir donc pour cela il faut faire
bouger l'europe pour améliorer votre
quotidien
la liste renaissance conduite par
nathalie l'oiseau elle additionne les
compétences pour y parvenir
donc le 26 même aller voter et soutenir
une europe qui vous protège et n'oublie
jamais que là où il ya une volonté il ya
toujours un chemin
laurence lyonnais votre conclusion si
vous voulez alors le 26 mai prochain
effectivement il n'y aura qu'un seul
tour un seul tour pour décider pour
relever la tête pour envoyer des députés
insoumise et un soumis au parlement
européen qui ne lâcheront rien devant
les deux lobbys qui ne changeront pas de
camp qui ne changeront pas d'avis en
cours de mandat et qu'ils se batteront
un pied à pied pour faire sortir des
dispositions des traités européens qui
nous empêche de préserver nos services
publics notre industrie et puis il y
aura qu'un seul tour aussi pour décider
que emmanuel macron et sa liste ne
sortiront pas en tête de cette élection
européenne ce serait vraiment absolument
contraire à tous les signaux qu'envoie
les français et les françaises depuis
plusieurs mois dans leur colère et pour
décider aussi qu'un autre avenir en
commun est possible en europe écologique
social et démocratique merci c'est au
tour de didier klein de conclure donc la
liste les européens qui veut développer
l'europe en ayant déjà vu ce qui ne
marche pas bien en essayant de
l'améliorer et vraiment avec une volonté
et j'invite vraiment où les les les
électeurs qu'il faut qu'ils soient
nombreux pour montrer que l'europe
représente encore quelque chose pour la
france donc c'est pour moi un point
essentiel est donc et permettre ainsi on
va dire à cette europe que nous nous
construisons ensemble que de se
développer et on va dire d'apporter au
monde industriel européen aux habitants
de cette grande europe tous les
bienfaits qu'elle peut apporter
et bien sûr on étend encore une fois
europhile mais pas eurobéats en étant
attentif merci didier klein
jacques ricart d'été vous êtes le
dernier à conclure merci donc ce sera
très très clair le 26 mai ce sera les
mondialistes ou la nation qui protège le
vrai le vrai débat c'est celui ci c'est
la nation c'est la nation qui peut nous
protéger
qui peut conserver nos services publics
nous ne sommes pas seuls en europe
nous avons tout un tas de coalition dans
d'autres pays qui nous défendent et qui
défendent cette idée de nation
nous sommes aujourd'hui très clairement
la nouveauté la voix de la jeunesse avec
jordan bardella et nous faut absolument
arriver en tête aussi au premier au
premier tour parce qu'il n'aura qu'un
seul face à emmanuel macron parce
qu'évidemment évidemment c'est donner un
quitus à sa politique c'est évidemment
il arrivait en tête
merci beaucoup merci à tous les six
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vous
rappelle que d'autres débats auront lieu
sur votre chaîne régionale avec d'autres
candidats d'autres formations politiques
nous allons donner la parole à un
maximum de représentants dans le respect
des règles qui nous sont imposées par le
csa savoir l'équité des temps de parole
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis dans
un instant votre flash d'information
régionale puis dimanche en politique
continue avec francis letellier qui
reçoit ce midi un candidat tête de liste
aux élections européennes jordan
bardella du rassemblement national
profitez bien de votre dimanche à
bientôt